okay thank you very much thanks for the
invitation so indeed i'll be talking
about what I'm going to call how to
encrypt a functionality it's more
commonly called within the field the
question of software obfuscation as I've
learned from talking to people outside
the academic community is a horrible
horrible word and I'm trying to describe
it slightly differently also to evoke
different intuitions so what do we mean
by encrypting a functionality supposed
to do something there we go so that
should be the first question we asked
you know what is what does this need
what would it mean to encrypt the
functionality so what we're used to
thinking about is encrypting messages
right where I have a particular message
and I want to garble it up in a way
that's completely indecipherable right
so when we encrypt the message the
encrypted message becomes indecipherable
and completely useless that's by design
that's the point of encryption the way
we typically think of it but if I'm
thinking about a functionality a
functionality is supposed to be
functional that's the whole point of it
while we're calling it a functionality
right so what would it mean to encrypt a
functionality so the first requirement
that i would like to have is that an
encrypted version of a functionality
should preserve the functionality right
i don't want to change what this object
is doing what functionality it's
allowing you to have access to instead
intuitively what I'd like to do is have
this encrypted functionality be in such
a such a form that it hides any secrets
that are used to compute its output
right so the functionality may have
several secrets built into it that it
makes use of in computing some output
based on some input and we want to hide
that process what was it what were the
secrets used and how are they used
before I move on let me just make the
setting as clear as I as I can so what
we're thinking about here is that I
start with a functionality description
also called software right it has some
input output behavior described some
function this is taken as input together
with some random
to a functionality encrypter ok this is
this device that we'd like to construct
and its output is an encrypted
functionality description also software
ok and what is the idea the idea is that
this encrypted functionality code the
software that's output is still ordinary
software it runs as is on ordinary
unsecured computer hardware and again as
I mentioned already should have the same
input output behavior as the original
functionality did so in particular what
this means is this randomness that was
used to to encrypt it can be safely
forgotten or destroyed it is not
actually needed from that point onward
in order to use the software it's just
the catalyst in this process and now
again intuitively what do we mean by a
by security we mean that if there's an
adversary that captures this encrypted
functionality description in its
entirety and examines all of it for
years that it's still unable to extract
the secrets that were used by the
original code whatever secrets were
originally built in to that description
ok now that is not totally clear yet I
haven't told you what it what I mean by
a secret I will get the formal
definitions just a little bit later in
the talk but before I do that I want to
give you some examples about what are
the kinds of secrets we might want to
protect inside software so some examples
of secrets for example we might want to
protect a cryptographic key right maybe
I want a functionality that is inside
some robot and we want to be able to
send it encrypted messages that the
robot can understand decrypt inside of
its head right in insiders brain decrypt
and then base its actions on what are
decrypted and now anyone can observe the
actions of the robot right that's the
output of the software we can't do
anything about that but we want to hide
everything else about what was the
message that I've decrypted what were
the keys that were used to do that
that's a prototypical example of what we
might suming the people
have complete access to the robots
internal exactly here we're assuming
that the robot is captured disassembled
every single electron is you know Christ
as it goes through the robot okay but
there are other kinds of secrets right
for example we might want to have some
software that looks nice and innocuous
but actually has a hidden back door
right so maybe there's some very rare
input you type in the special input and
then all of a sudden it gives you access
to some much more interesting
functionality right and we want to hide
not only what is this mysterious
password that gives you access to this
backdoor but even the existence of the
back door right that's the kind of thing
we might want to hide all those effect
is it's encrypted might huge that you're
having yes right right right we will
actually get to the very end of the talk
I'll mention a little bit about things
like that um now more generally than a
hidden back door other examples of
Secrets we might would want to hide are
rare inputs right so a functionality
again we're giving out the functionality
anyone can you know cry out inputs and
see what the outputs are but there may
be some rare inputs that are hard to
find that cause special behavior an
example might be if you have a control
system for a nuclear power plant plant
maybe there are a few situations that it
can't deal with and it leads to some
failsafe mode right so we don't want
necessarily someone who capture the
software to figure out what needs to do
to the sensors to make it go into
failsafe mode right so these are just
some other examples yes so in the
encrypted version
this behavior would still exist every
would still exist it's just that by
examining the code we don't want to give
you any clues to what those rare inputs
are that caused it to behave so you
would know that such a rare put input
existed but you wouldn't well you would
know that it might exist I mean you
don't know anything beyond what you can
of what well intuitively you don't want
you all you can observe is input output
behavior of the soft click for instance
you you by examining it you can see that
the certainly put produce the certain
answer yes but you just wouldn't know
how to do it well again suppose it's a
rare input so if you're giving it as a
black box it's hard for you to find that
in right that's that's what that's what
I meant by this type of a secret so how
does that sync up with being able to
examine the internal structure no no
that's the contradiction the point is
you can see the entire code and yet you
don't know if there are such a rare
inputs if they are what are they all
that should be kept hidden from you okay
all right oops okay that was not
intentional um right now there are also
other types of rare inputs that might
exist in a piece of software like
vulnerabilities right unintentional rare
inputs maybe when the software designer
was writing the code he made some
mistakes now we're all good software
developers so we tested it very you know
extensively this is a rare input that
you wouldn't normally find but it's
there and if that way or input was found
that it could be used to to exploit this
vulnerability in the software that would
be a nice thing we would like to hide
right what is this rare input that
causes this bad behavior
right indeed in this case the person
who's applying this functionality
encrypter doesn't even know what he's
necessarily hiding right if you turn
that on its head there's the question of
patched vulnerabilities right so when
Microsoft for example find some bug in
Windows and it wants to release a patch
this is actually a big problem because
it generates the patch that sends it out
into the wild it takes a long time for
these patches to actually find their way
into everyone's computer so what
attackers actually do is they look at
the patch reverse-engineer what the
actual bug was and then use it to attack
all the unpatched machines right but if
we could again take that functionality
the functionality of the pack and
encrypt it then it would be hard to
figure out what it is that it's patchy
right that would again be this rare
input that is that is hidden um more
generally we might want to hide also
algorithms themselves right perhaps the
way in which some functionality is
producing its output is some new and
interesting algorithm this is actually
the first thing that most people think
about when they want to hear obfuscation
I actually think it's one of the least
interesting applications but it's
definitely an interesting one and then
of course you could have multiple such
secrets right if you had a drone for
example that you're going to send over
North Korea you're worried about it
being captured you know it is assembled
everything's going to be looking inside
it we want to hide many many things
maybe about a single piece of software
right so this is the cut is the problem
that we want to solve is these are the
kinds of secrets we like that we'd like
to protect now before I move on I want
to step back and also think about what
this question means and sort of more
human terms right so what basically what
we're asking here is can you keep a
secret even if an adversary captures
your brain in its entirety watches every
neuron firing in your brain every
electron moving around while you are
thinking about the secret
that we want that you want to protect
right that's the human analogue of this
of this problem I think it's just a
beautiful and really fascinating
question yes Suh develop green our
brains are the organizing that way maybe
in your scientists was just give up
right it's fairly unlikely as you'll see
but yeah so I caught this course on
philosophy in theoretical computer
science and my student Andy Drucker gave
a whole presentation on you know what if
you had a brain which was homomorphic
Lee encrypted right stored somewhere
else could this life change the base and
philosophy of minds right actually I
want to take your question and use it
just just to point out one difference
here so some people think about how
morphic encryption as something similar
to what we're doing here it's
fundamentally different in the sense
that if you were to home orphic lee
encrypt your brain then all of the
answers it produces would also being
prepared right right so you would only
be able to think in an encrypted form
you would never be able to actually
speak to another human being because i
made the decryption key is somewhere
else like in your neck right but in this
case what's going on is that we're
treating that all together we're saying
that in fact you're able to talk to
normal human beings here but you know
able to speak in a normal language and
yet the secrets that were held inside
your brain should be protected okay so
great so it's a wonderful question um
where do we stand in terms of attacking
this question before I tell you that
let's take us short walk down memory
lane to think about an analogy of
encrypting messages so humans have dealt
with the problem of encrypting messages
for for eons right and if you go back a
couple of eons well cryptography was
really an art right and if I wanted to
send a secret message to someone
something I might do is call my friend
shave off his head write the message
that I want to spend on his scalp wait
for his hair to grow back and then send
them along to deliver the message right
so this doesn't actually use the method
in ancient Greek times yes
yeah round trip there are many there are
many vulnerabilities here and very many
many drawbacks it's a really clever idea
right i mean it's it's a very
interesting idea but it's very easy to
defeat if i know this is what you're
going to do i just start shaving
everyone's heads and i figure out what
messages are coming in it's a type of
security by obscurity right and this is
problematic this is why well one of the
reasons why they didn't have ecommerce
in ancient Greece one of many reasons um
we don't do this anymore right now what
do we do we take well we use math right
we take a message we feed it to our say
for example and out pops an encrypted
message right and math is hard we know
this from such reputable sources Barbie
and hard math based encryption
revolutionized the field right it opened
up a new world in securing data okay
great now you can put an encrypted
message on someone shape okay exactly
now what about for encrypting
functionalities what about this question
of soft crop the station today the state
of the art is very much like the state
of the art for encryption thousands of
years ago encrypting functionality is
very much an art form sometimes quite
literally an art form this is an actual
winning entry from the international
office cated c code contest this is
actually the Shah cryptographic hash
function algorithm it's beautiful very
clever you know cleverly constructed but
if someone actually looks at this and
then looked at it carefully it'll only
take a few minutes or hours depending on
your skill level to figure out what's
going on and indeed there are many
clever ideas known every single one of
them is broken all the ones that are
publicly publicly known and in general
this has caused a situation of security
by obscurity for this for this area so
what I want to tell you about is that
last year in a joint work with guard
Gentry halevi Rick ova and waters at Fox
for the first time we gave a method for
attacking this question the general
purpose question of
cooking functionalities using the hard
math I'm sorry good so the point is that
it is encrypted and then given to the
adversary the interest rate can run it
as many times as it likes right there's
no limit yeah I will talk about the
accessibility as I mentioned I haven't
told you the definition yet right then
we have to be very careful about how we
define things okay so um this is just
the ad portion now I'll clarify this in
a moment um so hopefully this will open
up some a new world for secular
computing and some perhaps similar way
to a math based in data encryption did I
do want to stress that while this is a
polynomial time transformation that we
have the polynomial is very large and
the overhead is far too large for
practical use at the current moment so
it's very important for me to make that
clear um before I get to definitions
which I which I definitely want to get
into let me take a slide aside to look
at this question from the viewpoint of
compression so let's think about it this
way first of all from from now on in the
stock first when I talk about software I
mean by that a boolean circuit for some
function f okay and and let's take this
viewpoint what is software software can
be seen as a way of compressing a
function right if you write down a
function as a truth table that can be
very very big software is a nice compact
way of describing a function right in
fact it's a it's an essential way you
can think about software now when we
think about and indeed another point
here is that if you want to perfectly
encrypt some functionality just provide
the truth table right the truth table is
will only give you input output access
the problem is that the truth table will
just be too big in most cases to be for
this to be a reasonable solution now
when we think about compression
we see one of the contradictions he
write or one of the seeming
contradictions in general how do you
compress things you compress a string by
revealing or exploiting the structure
that is present within that object right
if you think about the classic lentils
live algorithm it essentially reveals a
context-free grammar for the string that
you want to compress right and this
seems very essentials is our basic
intuition for how compression should
work and yet what is this question that
we're asking right where the
functionality encryption question is
basically asking can you compress a
function without revealing its structure
right is it is this somehow is this
something that we can do clearly this
can only make sense with respect to a
computationally bounded adversary that's
what we're considering here okay all
right on so let's now talk a little bit
about definitions how would we define
this notion of encrypting of
functionality so perhaps the most
natural definition is what we call the
virtual blackbox definition this is the
definition that we we proposed in an old
joint work with several co-authors back
in cryptic 2001 and intuitively what
does it say it says that a polynomial
time adversary given the encrypted
version of the functionality can be
simulated with only a polynomial number
of black box accesses to the truth table
of the function okay so you can think of
it as you know creating this black box
that you do when I when I encrypt it
somehow it becomes just like giving a
giving a black box to the after the
functionality now it's actually
extremely unsurprising that this is an
impossible notion to achieve okay in
particular think about the following
trivial adversary the adverse ER e is an
identity map it just takes as input the
encrypted software and outputs the
encrypted software right this adversary
has now managed to compress the function
right whereas given black box access to
a non learnable function at least that's
not that should not be possible right
now as far as an attack
goes this is not a very devastating
attack you know an identity map is
usually not something that generates a
lot of headlines now the reality is
slightly more complex than that so in
the same paper we construct some
contrived of self eating functions okay
these self eating functions have this
somewhat remarkable property that any
compressed version of the function
reveals a secret that cannot be
extracted given only black box access to
the function okay so and the I I call it
a self-feeding function because that's
kind of the idea you can kind of feed
the compressed version of the function
to itself piece by piece and after it
verifies that you have indeed bedded a
version of itself it out put some secret
right so it really wants to reveal its
secret but in order to do so it wants
you to give it a compressed version of
the of the function so that is more
problematic right and that shows some of
the subtleties in defining what a
software secret would mean what what is
a secret that is reasonable to protect
within a functionality nevertheless I
want to point out that this is still an
unsatisfying impossibility result right
it just shows that there are these
certain contrived counter examples there
are no problematic generic attacks that
are known for general functions that
you'd like to that you'd like to
obfuscate unless you also have some very
contrived auxiliary information that
you're giving so putting that aside in
general the question is is still
actually quite an open question about
what secrets can you exactly protect
within within an office cater piece of
software now in that same paper we also
propose an alternative weaker definition
that we call indistinguishability
obfuscation okay so what is
indistinguishable attia obfuscation say
and this is the version for which there
are no impossibility results okay so
this says given two equivalent circuits
c0 and c1 let's they have the same size
then a polynomial-time adversary cannot
distinguish the encryption of one
circuit from
encryption of the other circuit okay so
this is saying that you know this is
kind of an information throughout a
viewpoint on encrypting a functionality
right it's saying that among all the
different compressed versions of a
particular functionality after
encryption you can't distinguish one
from the other right now um and I want
to stress that there are no
impossibilities alts known for this for
this notion another thing that's
interesting about it is that it captures
a notion of best possible office keishon
so let me let me tell you what I mean by
that this is rigorously formulated by a
gold luster and roth bloom in 2007
suppose that you had a circuit see that
had some ideal obfuscator form C prime
ok it hit every sir every secret that
was within that circuit that was worth
hiding ok and of course here I really
mean a distribution over circuits and a
distribution over ideal encryptions well
now let's think about it if i look at my
indistinguishability obfuscation is this
this ian this encrypt functionality and
i consider what happens when i encrypt
the original circuit and I could and
then I also consider what happens when I
encrypt the ideally obfuscated adverse
of it by the definition these are
indistinguishable to the adversary right
so that means in fact whatever needed to
be hidden was already hidden by the
indistinguishability obfuscation right
this captures us this idea um and you
can kind of abstract this out by by by
by saying that essentially speaking up
to some issues some there are some
technical issues of the size of the
circuits here but up to those technical
issues in the zoom jiggle the
obfuscation hides all high double
secrets right if it could have been
hidden then we can hide it if it can't
be hidden well then of course we won't
hide it yes so
actually either these definitions
captures a lot of examples that you gave
for instance yes the back door that's
different function absolutely yeah so
indeed from a theoretical standpoint
it's a very interesting question and it
was really open for a long time this is
cute that its best possible it has these
nice properties but is it actually
useful for anything and that was largely
an open question we now have substantial
evidence that it's actually very useful
for a number of applications I probably
won't get to that in this talk but
there's a there's some work that i have
with student brent waters where we
showed how to use indistinguishable
adolphus keishon to construct a lot of
classical cryptographic objects and also
solve some open questions and sort of
the floodgates have opened then there
are many many results now yes can
formalize a notion of something that's
almost a black box except that it can
take its own description is input and
then you know wondering could you say
that price things ability obfuscation
gives you you know that behavior or
works every time you can't do something
contrived like this right right um I'm
not sure about that it's a little bit
see that you because you can also have
like two pairs of snakes eating each
other right so you have to be very
careful about how are you you know how
you define such things um so anyway in
this paper the Fox paper we gave the
first mathematical candidate for
indistinguishable the obfuscation for
general circuits based on a concrete
assumption over idea lattices I actually
will not state the exact assumption in
this in this talk but you will see the
flavor of it later on so this gives this
kind of best possible obfuscation and as
I mentioned we can use it to to actually
achieve a lot of interesting
cryptographic objects not everything
that I mentioned the first slide we know
how to do with indistinguishable the
obfuscation but many things we can do
now on the other hand I mentioned that
the negative results that we have for
virtual black box office keishon
are somewhat contrived write these weird
self eating functions these are not the
things you would typically want to
obfuscate right so this is still a very
open area to try to understand where the
boundary lives however we have some
evidence that the obfuscation mechanism
we don't we've come up with of does give
you some type of virtual blackbox
protection let me let me be more clear
about that so we can prove an
unconditional result that says that if
your adversaries are limited to certain
natural algebraic attacks okay then
indeed we can actually achieve the
virtual blackbox notion okay so you
might that might be somewhat confusing
we have actual counter examples and yet
i'm saying i can unconditionally achieve
it this is because those algebraic
attacks prevent you from feeding
yourself the to yourself because you're
using some algebraic structures of black
box and the function that the the
functionality will be making use of the
internal structure of that algebraic
object okay but it can be seen as again
at some heuristic evidence that the
construction will hide all the secrets
that are present in natural software or
whatever that means I mean this is just
a heuristic evidence i also want to
mention although i'm not expert in
quantum computing means that so far
there are no known polynomial time
quantum attacks to the methods that work
that will that will describe and i'll
try to focus in later on on why that is
where the where the the boundary seems
to be in terms of understanding that to
the extent that i understand it okay so
good so how do we do it before I jump
into the actual math let's take a kids
view of this okay so I'm going to
describe what the functionality
encryption should mean by taking an
analogy to magic tricks ok now I'm very
fortunate to have a five-year-old and an
eight-year-old boy boys that have to
two boys and it's a very fun age because
at that age kids know some math but math
operations that we think of as being
trivial or highly complicated for them
right these are very computationally
intensive operations so you may have
heard of the following math trick for
kids so you say write down a number
between one and ten and the kid
dutifully writes it down then multiply
it by two difficult operation for for a
kid right so carefully figure that
multiply the result by five again
difficult operation now / your original
number okay beautifully doesn't I will
guess the answer the answer is sending
the kid is amazed right Wow how in the
world were you able to figure that out
right really remarkable now what we
would like yes we're in the United
States you're right right right right
these are all these are outside the
model okay so all right so what's our
idea the idea is we want to take we
think about this in an analogy to this
that we want mathematically encrypted
software to feel like this to the
adversary the adversity should feel like
the kid felt in this in this math trick
right in this magic trick essentially
the encrypted software will be the
sequence of mathematical operations
where each operation looks completely
random and unrelated to whatever the
original software was right but again
the adversary or the user beautifully
can carry out these operations but then
finally at the end somehow everything
will cancel out right all of the
randomness will cancel out and you'll
only get the reveal at the end the
output of the software right so this is
what we would like to be able to do and
and again looking back the the
adversary's just like our kid can't look
back and figure out because of his
computationally bounded nature
this cancellation to place how it
happened and how this output was
suddenly formed at the end okay now
unlike kids our adversaries are actually
very adversarial and it turns out that
is the essence of this of this problem
is that an adversary won't just do what
he's told right if he is the software
tells them to do these operations he
might try to modify the operation to do
something else in order to try to
extract some information out so really
the key that we want to achieve here is
a way of building a mathematical
structure where certain operations can
be meaningfully done whereas other
operations become meaningless that the
results become meaningless and we want
to be able to do this in a very precise
way so that only one particular path
exists for your computation anything
else you do gets do something
meaningless intuitively okay so um so
how do we do this we do this by going
through an abstraction though with that
I'm going to call an algebraic jigsaw
puzzle okay this figure just looks cool
has nothing to do with our favor um so
so what is the building block of an
algebraic jigsaw puzzle so it's a
simplification of something called an
approximate multi linear map that was
recently introduced by guard Gentry on
and halevy our simplified version of it
actually eliminates a lot of cryptic
cryptanalytic techniques that were
problematic in the original case
something like this can also be done
over the integers I'm going to describe
to a polynomial based approach I'm I
want you to think about this algebraic
jigsaw puzzle as kind of a two party
game okay one player in this game is the
jigsaw puzzle maker okay this is a guy
who makes these certain algebraic values
using some secrets that he has excuse me
and he gives these values to the other
party which is the jigsaw puzzle solver
it's a non-interactive game
the jigsaw puzzle solver has a
particular algorithm in his head that he
applies to these values that he's
received to put these pieces together
okay and at the end when he's put all
these excel fizzles pieces together he
should be getting at the end and
encoding of zero okay I'll make that
clear in just a moment and if he gets an
encoding of zero than the outputs one
otherwise the output zero okay and the
kind of assumptions we want to make is
that you can have two different
distributions of these puzzles of these
jigsaw puzzles that are computationally
indistinguishable to any polynomial time
jigsaw puzzle solver so you can give
these two puzzles and the because they
seem to fit together in similar ways a
computation we bounded adversary can
distinguish them from each other let's
get more niño as I already mentioned
only certain algebraic operations will
make sense that's the idea that's a key
point that we want to achieve here okay
so let's get more let's get to let's get
our hands dirty a little bit more so I
will be working in we'll start with
looking at polynomials over the integers
modulo cyclotomic polynomial X to the n
plus 1 okay and will also pick a random
large prime Q and look at the same thing
mod Q okay the same object mark you now
x to the n plus 1 the way we choose it
and as a power of 2 here is irreducible
over the integers and as a consequence
it's not too difficult to see that the
version / q is a pseudo field so almost
everything has an inverse there just a
few bad zero divisors around okay but we
can think of it essentially as it was
kind of a essentially field okay now
what does the puzzle maker do what is
the jigsaw puzzle maker do he selects a
bunch of random secrets now the first
secret that he selects is a small
polynomial G were by small I mean that
the coefficients of every every
coefficient is small
I won't actually ever define exactly
quantitatively what i mean by small but
there's some flexibility and how we can
define it if you want you can think of
it as being polynomial in n okay and he
picks such a small polynomial G subject
to the constraint that when you mod out
by the ideal generated by G over the
integers so again with the original ring
then we wind up with something of order
P where P is a again a large random
prime okay let's just think about that
visually what it means and some simple
consequences looking deep here so again
I have this you know small polynomial g
I look at the lattice right that's
generated by the ideal of G right
generates a lattice over the integers
and the fact that when I Maud out by the
ideology I got a prime means that
there's a exactly a prime number of
points inside this parallelepiped right
and what this also means it's easy to
see is that if I start with any ordinary
integer in CP or between 0 and p minus 1
then what i can do is i can move it
right to its representative inside this
parallelepiped right and this will have
the property that a hat here will just
be a plus some small multiple of g right
and now why are we doing this because p
is gigantic so an element and zp could
be very very big and notions as big and
small are going to be very important to
us ok so by mapping it back inside the
fundamental parallelepiped here we get a
small polynomial that acts like a right
so good all right the puzzle maker will
also have some other random secrets
these will just be large random
polynomials and in our queue ok z0 up to
Z K now
I want to make these puzzle pieces right
that I want to be able to give to this
jigsaw verifier so if I want to encode a
element a in zp so I'm going to be
working essentially over zp here at a
level which corresponds to the set 0
okay then what do i do I take this
element a I map it to its representative
okay a hat that I just drew and then I
add this random noise ok I take another
small polynomial are and I and i add a
hat plus R times G right so if I sorry
just looking at the picture again right
this is just saying that I'm keeping the
position here I'm just moving around a
you know by by by translating buy it by
by summit random element at small random
element of the lattice ok so so that's
essentially that's why the this
information about a here is preserved
right despite this random perturbation
what's right so again are you can think
of it as coming from some Gaussian
distribution it's not all that important
but but it's a Gaussian distribution
with small coefficients um it's actually
not exactly the way I drew it here what
we really do is we we sample from the
discrete Gaussian after translating buy
a hat but that's not that's not so
important ok for the ranges of
parameters that we can use it even this
is secure as far as we know ok and then
I will so this is this is kind of my
representative of a of the of the of the
element a and CP and now I want to say
that it's at this level corresponding to
the set 0 and the way I write that is
why i divide division here's arbitrary
it just helps it visually to see what's
going on I / this large
and in polynomial z0 where z 0
corresponds to the fact that we're at
level zero so these are my puzzle pieces
let's think now about what are some
natural operations we can do with these
puzzle pieces and what are things that
won't work and sorry I should make one
point here this error term is critical
right so the error term is something
that we want to keep small so as we do
operations we want to keep track of the
fact that this error term is small that
is what is going to help maintain
meaningfulness here right because if the
error term becomes too big relative to Q
then we lose information right because
work we would go we would wrap around
mod Q and then all the information might
be lost okay and this is also the part
that seems to make this approach
resistant to known quantum algorithms so
what can we do with these puzzle pieces
that's the question well let's think
about it so one thing we can do is think
about if we had two different puzzle
pieces for two elements a and B both at
the same level right well these are nice
looking objects right these are nice
lesson fractions you can add them they
have a common denominator and indeed we
would get an encoding of a plus B right
and their words there would be a
slightly larger error term but still a
nice small little error term right so
that's nice that's something that we're
permitting there's an operation that
we're permitting on the other hand just
and again this is this is all very
intuitive right now but suppose you had
two elements a and B which were a
different level one was at level 0 on
two levels you one then we don't want to
let you add these things and indeed if
you try to add them you would get these
very annoying expressions in the in the
numerator which would destroy
information well okay they don't
actually destroy intrusion but they
would destroy the structure right
because you would again potentially
wraparound mod Q and all sorts of bad
things could happen so we think this is
being junked and this is like a
non-permitted operation the adversary
could try to do it if it wanted to
if it did it would get something that it
can't really make use of okay good what
about multiplication so if I have a
let's say an element a at level 0 and
would be at level 1 and I multiply these
things again this looks pretty nice
right so we would now only thing what
changes now the denominator has 0 0 Z 1
in it which is now means that it's an
encoding at the set 0 comma 1 but again
we would multiply a and B and we would
get in it somic again now even even
bigger error term but still small right
because everything we started with in
the numerator of a small when you
multiply two small things it's still
small as far as we're concerned okay you
can do this a few times we can we can
let you we can pick the parameters so
that you can do these multiplications
some limited number of times and not
overflow the the air okay and another
point sorry that I want to make is that
I note that multiplication jumps levels
right so I can't do this the same level
I can't take an encryption sorry and
encoding ave at level 0 and recording a
beer level 0 multiplied them without
getting a squared term here which i
haven't told you why that's bad yet but
it will be bad and and this is what's
going to enforce the type of multi
linearity in what the adversary can and
cannot do okay all right similarly
another thing that an adversary cannot
do is uh is divided oh my goodness how
much time you actually have left 15
minutes okay all right I will just give
you some flavor of the construction and
then I'll have to skip a lot of slides
again if you try to divide and then
there would be a problematic a
problematic thing in the expression
which could cause things Dover flow
cause things to lose their algebraic
structure that we'd like to preserve
okay yes
only use that time to add two numbers
using different or that are in different
levels you get John yes can I see that
as a variable no no not not not really
so sorry let me go back so when we add
at different levels it's not just that
we get Z 0 Z 1 in the denominator the
problem is of disease chopped in the
numerator right and the disease again
they have large coefficients these are
chosen completely at random so in
particular their coefficients are you
know half of them are bigger than Q over
to right so we will lose structure
Mudkip and in fact even G will have some
large think so again we'll lose the
structure that we would like to preserve
ok um there's one final piece that I
need to tell you about in an algebra
puzzle to make it useful right so so far
I've showed you how to make these puzzle
pieces and you can combine them a
certain way is multiply them in certain
ways that's fine but you always wind up
with this crazy encoded thing right you
will you can't someone who doesn't know
these secret values G and disease will
never be able to tell what it is that
he's dealing with right so the final
thing we want to do is let you check if
an encoding is an encoding of 0 at an
appropriate level ok so in particular
I'm going to look at the level that
corresponds to you know the full set 01
up decay ok so what is what should an
encoding of 0 look like it should be a
small multiple of g / this product right
now I want to give you an ability to
check if that's the case this is going
to correspond to like figuring out what
the output is so the final puzzle piece
is something that lets you check this
and in it we construct in a very natural
way what I'll do is I'll give you the
reciprocal of this part I mean I don't
know what the r is but i can give you
the reciprocal of this part and then
multiply it by a moderately law
charge polynomial right not something
that's really small not something that's
really big but let's say Q to the
two-thirds size right now why am i doing
that because now I can use this to test
if something is 0 right if I multiply it
out I'll get h times are are again we're
controlling we're being very careful
about what it is it's going to be small
way smaller than Q to the one-third so
then you'll be able to test whether this
polynomial is small or not if it's small
when we know that we started with a zero
on the other hand if I if I had some
nonzero element then I'm going to have
something which has a G in the in the
denominator and again G was a random
small polynomial the reciprocal of
witches we believe to be computationally
indistinguishable from just the
uniformly random polynomial okay so this
would again destroy not only destroy
structure but it would it would almost
do it overall or with our overall and
probability lead to a large result and
the other point is that because we chose
H to be moderate in size you cannot use
this zero testing element at any level
except for this level okay and that
comes back to this multi linearity point
that I was making earlier right we let
you go step by step in a multi linear
way up to this level and after that if
you want to be able to test 40 you're
stuck if you try to do anything else and
the zero test element becomes useless to
you okay now that's it that is what
these puzzles what the building blocks
for these puzzles look like I gave you
only a very intuitive description of why
they seemed secure and that's because
that's pretty much what we have okay so
with these objects there are many
[ __ ] at cryptanalytic techniques that
we've tried to break them they seem to
be resilient to that so it's a new
family of assumption so we're making
them right that that when you encode in
this way that you really have to really
cannot do anything except for
these few permitted operations and you
can only do those in a in a bounded in a
bounded way okay before the era gets too
big so yes
that is certainly one of the critical of
goals if you were able do that then that
would almost certainly break this game
but we don't know how to do that as far
as me so just to give an example of what
type of an assumption we might make
let's take a simple case where the k
equals 1 so we just go to 0 or 1 and
let's say what I do is I pick a bunch of
numbers alpha at random and I give you
an encoding of alpha 1 times alpha 2
alpha 1 times alpha 3 and alpha 2 times
alpha 3 okay at you know this level 0
and 1 now why did I do it this way it's
because if you if you're only given the
permitted operations right the ones that
I gave you you cannot construct alpha 1
alpha 2 alpha 3 over the level 0 1 right
it's always going to be an extra term
you won't be able to cancel out ok so
the kind of assumption that we would
make is that if I gave you these
elements that's indistinguishable from
you giving you the same elements but
we're just something completely random
instead right instead of giving you this
actual product which is information
threateningly fixed here if I just give
you something at random you can tell the
difference because the permitted
operations cannot distinguish between
these two cases um all right now I want
to give you some idea about how we
actually use these building blocks to
encrypt our functionality I probably
will not be able to do this I will
attempt it though so we'll look at NC 1
functions so NC 1 log depth or log depth
functions you can even forget what that
means the only thing that's important to
remember is that such functions there's
this beautiful Barrington's theorem that
can be applied which let you encode
every such function as a set of 2 k
let's say matrices ok where if I want to
evaluate the funk
at some particular input all I need to
do is is multiply matrices according to
the bits that are selected by the input
so in this example if the input is 1 0
then I would you know select the first
matrix among these to this sorry the
second Matrix among these to the first
matrix like these two and so on so when
I multiply them all out and if I do that
then I'll get the identity matrix if the
output was 0 and some other fixed matrix
and if the I if the output was was one
this is efficient yeah these are all all
this is efficient than anyone can do it
ok so as a warm-up idea if I wanted to
obfuscate this program I this is a
program now ok maybe what I'll do is um
I'll I'll get out these matrices except
for the part that corresponds to the
actual program that's see here I'll only
give you the one matrix that's that's
relevant I skipped a step above this
being a universal circuit it's not that
important this is a terrible idea it
doesn't work at all just because again
it's a publicly computable function so I
can just see what makes you give and
read off what the circuit was right so I
can just read off what the actual
circuit they started rumors but anyway
what do we like about this right what do
I like about matrix matrices in products
why do I like this this this this this
notion of computation because it's multi
linear right if I'm multiplying a bunch
of matrices that is kind of the
prototypical multi linear operation in
the entries the matrix right and I just
gave you an algebraic structure which
supports these kind of multi linear
operations right so that's why we
started looking at this this type of a
of a structure now what we can do is we
can add some randomization this is an
old idea of killians maybe even earlier
that i'm not sure but at least as old as
Killian but not as old as he is but
anyway okay so we can we can add these
matrices so that the product is
preserved right you multiply on the left
and right by our some are inverse the
inverse is all nicely cancel out when
you do the product exactly as you're
told and this is now hiding some
information right this is this is good
there's some progress towards what we
would like to do and now we can prove up
to some lie that I'm not telling you
that if you were to do this if you were
to give this as your obfuscating a form
of a program there are only essentially
three types of attacks sorry one are
attacks that don't respect the algebraic
structure okay and maybe our degree not
equal to one in these entries here but
remember that was why I generated these
algebraic puzzles right it's exactly to
force this force you to be to the work
with this algebraic structure so this is
the part that we're hopefully going to
solve just by using these algebraic
jigsaw puzzles there are two other kinds
of attacks I cannot possibly cover them
in negative minutes that I have anyway
there are a few other kinds of attacks
we can actually prove that there are the
only ones that remain and there's some
additional randomization that we can do
to take care of this okay I'm now
skipping over I'm very sorry for this
because the quantum workshop i will use
quantum notation exactly this one moment
oh we're just my first and last matrices
here I'm any we're going to just compute
single products these can just be you
know
row and column vectors anyway if you do
all of this then we can actually prove
it we can prove that if an adversary is
limited to the algebraic attacks that
are supported by these algebraic jigsaw
puzzles that I that I that I presented
those pieces that I presented then there
are no attacks to this even as a virtual
black box office cater okay and this is
the best evidence that we have for our
office keishon methods that that they
are secure because we can rule out these
kind of algebraic attacks and when it
comes to the underlying algebraic
realization the one I was just just
presenting to you there we only have
cryptanalytic evidence that it seems to
be to resist both classical and quantum
attacks okay so that is the essential
idea the flavor at least hopefully of
how these new mathematical office
keishon techniques work we can then
bootstrap from NC 1 functionalities to
all circuits using fully homomorphic
encryption this is not too complicated
but again I don't have time to go over
it I'm sorry again one nice thing that
this proof illustrates though is that
here we only need to use the
indistinguishability obfuscation
property we don't need to use anything
stronger about it and here actually
prevent to the entire proof behind more
time so anyway to wrap up now that we
have mathematical approaches to general
purpose obfuscation it seems to open up
a new world really as the negative
results suggested that we did I
mentioned at the beginning I think as a
community we were generally very
pessimistic about this possibility
actually being being there right of
being able to have a way of obfuscation
general purpose
we're in any meaningful way and there's
a whole host of implications that are
now being studied and and and and and
proven based on these these ideas and
and then one of the one of the programs
here is to think of this idea of
indistinguishability obfuscation is
being the hub for all of cryptography
that basically you can do anything that
we did previously in cryptography by
going via this this one object but maybe
more interesting we also solve lots of
interesting new open questions all right
I already mentioned some of these cute
applications on let me just mention one
more thing because it was asked
previously which is there's this
question of well if someone gives you an
office gated piece of software you have
to be crazy to execute it right you have
no idea what this thing is doing its
going to maybe encrypt your hardness can
send it to someone I mean we have no
idea what it's going to do right so why
would you actually want to ever use and
an encrypted software encrypted
functionality as an end user so one of
the things that we can do is we can
combine this with ideas of zero
knowledge proofs right and I can provide
you with an with an encrypted
functionality and the proof that it's
not too bad you know it hides some
secrets but only secrets that you're
willing to have hid from you right so
for example maybe I want to create some
sort of software agent that will
purchase things so I don't want to give
you my credit card number so it'll prove
to you look this agent the only thing is
going to hide from you is this credit
card number everything else do you he's
going to behave exactly as you expect
right so all right with that and I'm pop
my apologies for going over time I'll
conclude the talk thank you
uh this proofs of honesty so again um in
terms of in principle it's known right
because we can actually just combine
zero-knowledge proofs that we already
have together with this these office
keishon techniques so so in principle
it's there here I think this is still a
beautiful research direction where the
research record here is to find out you
know when can you actually use it to
hide a meaningful secret and we have one
example that we published the results
about all those sort of meta example
we're using office kitchen to build a
better kind of zero and always from a
call so maybe it's not all that
interesting but in that we use another
zero knowledge for a call to prove that
you're off the station is good and then
you use it to build an even better as
you're not for a call but I think the
door is opening now and it's a lot to
the Explorer here the pictures so I
remember I had some other top what
looking you know Max and the
construction there i'm not sure if it's
the same or different I had the property
that if you take your element which
encodes something and you cut off the
bits from the end then you have
something which is well it doesn't
unique
information about what's included but
encoding the same thing several times
give you always the same output if you
cut off the end right does this give us
the extraction property I think you're
referring to a real one but you wouldn't
need for example if you use it for key
exchange or something yes right I might
have this year too it's irrelevant to us
here I think it's why I'm asking is that
I think that if you have this extraction
property that probably would be part of
secure because I think then you can
compute discrete logarithms so the right
so um so indeed one of the things that
we were doing here is we're cutting a
lot of a very useful stuff from
multilinear things approximately linear
map constructions which we don't need
and which do eliminate some of these
some of these things now there is given
the zero test it is still possible to
extract some information but as far as I
know that doesn't allow for a quantum
attack but because i think this
extraction you can run shaw's I Croatian
right so so here the reason Bolivia is
like a little bit i know so the reason
we can't run Shor's algorithm on this
thing is because of those error terms
yeah right the point is that ensures
Agra you have to compute a uniform
distribution right over all things in z
pz p is irrelevant quantity for us here
right p is enormous right so when you're
multiplying despite that constant term
think of it that way that will itself
cause an overflow for the air p in
general for us is much much bigger than
Q so this is a real loose and that then
you'll lose functionality I think
another reason the thing is ensure you
you make this function table like a to
the everything and then you apply a free
transfer ended and now if a to date
something at a to the something plus
order it's not it's not the same
representation
free from someone right with Muslims I
did now that is not that's not the
critical problem though the critical
problem will be that when you go far
enough in that table it just won't be
the right thing so when you apply the
Fourier transform yours get junk out
close x means exponent you again the
reason is because of the error terms
right the error term will grow too much
as you try to fill out that table I'm
convinced that I think the Mon
uniqueness section but we can talk about
sure oh I see the non-uniqueness is more
important okay other questions sure yeah
can you control the size of your render
matrices I mean it's a nice trick but if
they do they have to be too large then
you also in trouble right so in this
case if we're using for example
barrington stand there just in the
version that I described it would be six
by six oh these are not big in fact it
even works a two-by-two matrices there's
a variant that will even work with you
by 2 matrices so that's not that's not
but it's still incredibly inefficient
let me be very clear about this okay
this would still take a tiny little
program and it would become petabytes in
length I mean this is highly problematic
right now we need significant research
needs to be done and improving proofs
can in principle
yeah yes yes the it sufficiently
efficient proofs exist for this type of
zero knowledge again remember we're
against computationally bounded
adversary's that's in any way inherent
right and what we're doing so once you
have computationally once your comp
additionally if it bounded adversary's
than even non-interactive such things I
mean even special kinds of these things
exist so efficiency from a polynomial
time point of view is not the issue
efficiency can where practical kind of
has totally different story but yeah
okay